In November 2021, the Supreme Court will hear
a case going to the core of how the United States
understands the human person and justice: Ramirez
v. Collier. the case involves Texas denying a
death row convict the right to audible prayer
and touch in prayer in his final moments.
But the principles go much deeper. For centuries,
the Western legal tradition has justified capital
punishment partially because imminent execution
can facilitate repentance, thereby necessitating
the presence of ministers. And more broadly, many
religious traditions emphasize the vital role of
ministers giving comfort to the dying. History
is replete with instances of deepened faith on
death row. Protecting the presence of ministers
at one's final moments represents a principle
at the core of the American founding: Government
power should be shaped around religious duties.
Ramirez presents the Supreme Court with an
excellent opportunity to continue re-anchoring
religion clause jurisprudence in American history
and tradition. Here, that means ensuring respect
for the dignity and faith of inmates in theirlast hour.
What do you think? Do you think all death row inmates should have the right tothe comfort of clergy in their final moments?
Let us know in our poll. Also let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.